Marvel fans have been waiting years for a
Black Widow solo movie, and from the first
trailer it looks like we'll be getting some
awesome action scenes, and fantastic new characters
joining the MCU, including a brand new villain,
Taskmaster.
And with Marvel's history of twist reveals
for their villains and the actor playing Taskmaster
currently a secret, fans have already begun
to speculate about who's really beneath the
helmet.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm going to explain all the hidden
clues in the Black Widow teaser that reveal
Taskmaster's true identity and the secret
twist in the movie.
Also, keep watching for details of an incredible
thousand-dollar gift-card giveaway with bonus
goodies, all thanks to this video's sponsor
Marvel Collect!
By Topps.
Quick warning, there will, of course, be speculation
and potential spoilers for Black Widow.
As a super-spy movie, Black Widow will be
full of characters double-crossing each other
and hiding secret intentions.
And when Taskmaster is revealed, it will likely
be someone that's already close to Natasha
in some way in order to magnify the impact
of that twist.
Potential candidates include Florence Pugh's
Yelena, Rachel Weisz's Melina, and O.T.
Fagbenle's mysterious character Mason.
I'm going to say straight away that Red Guardian
won't be Taskmaster because he's clearly fighting
the villain in this scene.
However, there is another character from Natasha's
past who we also need to consider.
There's a popular theory that Taskmaster is
actually Hawkeye in disguise.
I'm going to explain why that's highly unlikely,
but first let's review the evidence.
The theory suggests the villain's skilled
bow and arrow technique fits perfectly with
Clint Barton's expertise as an archer.
If this twist were true, it would be particularly
shocking because Nat and Clint have been great
friends throughout their time together in
the MCU, despite being on opposite sides for
a while during Civil War:
"We're still friends aren't we?"
"Depends on how hard you hit me."
And – spoilers for Avengers: Endgame – when
they go to Vormir to recover the Soul Stone,
Nat even sacrifices herself so Clint can live
and get his own Disney+ TV show.
So, their friendship and Natasha's future
sacrifice would make Hawkeye being the twist
villain in her own solo movie feel especially
cruel and improbable.
The only real way it could make sense is if
this moment is a flashback to the time that
Clint came after Natasha on SHIELD's orders.
"I got on S.H.I.E.L.D.'s radar in a bad way.
Agent Barton was sent to kill me.
He made a different call."
It would be pretty weird though if Clint suited
up as Taskmaster for this mission unless he'd
somehow gone rogue or was being mind-controlled
by someone else like he was by Loki in the
first Avengers movie.
That all feels like a big stretch though and
the final nail-in-the-coffin for this theory
could be that Taskmaster draws the bow with
his right hand whereas the MCU's Clint is
left-handed when he uses the bow.
What's probably going on in this scene is
that Taskmaster has copied Hawkeye's archery
skills from a previous encounter with him
and is now using them against Natasha.
That's because Taskmaster has the power of
photographic reflexes meaning he can mimic
and duplicate the moves, tricks and skills
of anyone he observes.
Another possibility is that this is the Budapest
event that's been referenced so many times
in the Infinity Saga and that Taskmaster is
fighting Clint and imitating him in the moment.
"Just like Budapest all over again."
"You and I remember Budapest very differently."
"..long way from Budapest."
For our next Taskmaster candidate we need
to take a look at new Black Widow character,
Melina Vostokoff played by Rachel Weisz who
intriguingly revealed some juicy details about
Melina during an interview at Comic Con.
Just before we get to that though, a huge
thanks to Marvel Collect!
By Topps for sponsoring this video.
Because December is Fan Appreciation Month,
Topps Digital are giving away one free collectible
every single day this month for MARVEL Collect!
users to collect and complete the set of 30.
I just signed up and have already picked up
awesome Black Widow and Spider-Man cards,
and there are tons more cards coming including
Captain America, Thor and Iron Man.
And don't worry if you miss any, because you
can easily collect cards from any day you
forget to sign in.
Now if you're a Marvel fan who wants to prove
yourself worthy, you'll need to collect five
select cards in December for a chance to win
a grand prize of $1000 of Disney.com gift
cards, a $250 Midtown Comics digital gift
card, and $100 worth of in-app currency to
spend in the Marvel Collect! app.
To enter the giveaway, click the link in the
video description to download the MARVEL Collect!
app, register a user name, and make sure you
collect all five of the following cards: Spider-man,
Captain America, Thor, Iron Man and Black
Widow.
Then click the Gleam link in the video description
below to submit your details.
The Marvel Collect! app is available in both
the iTunes App store and Google Play store
worldwide and is totally free both to download
and to play.
There's an enormous range of trading cards
to collect from both the MCU movies and the
original comic book characters.
In fact, whenever a new Marvel movie comes
out, Topps releases brand new cards, so I'm
looking forward to collecting new Black Widow
characters like Red Guardian and Yelena.
By downloading the app, you can start to collect
all of your favourite Marvel characters.
As your collection grows, you'll earn awards
for completing sets.
And with new collectibles being released every
day, you can have fun trading with fans from
all around the world.
OK, back to Taskmaster's secret identity.
Speaking to EW, Rachel Weisz explained that
Melina is a seasoned assassin who's been through
the Black Widow programme five times, and
that she "was deeply involved in a scientific
experiment."
Weisz then said she couldn't talk about that
any further, and this itself means that her
character Melina is very likely to factor
into one of the movie's major twists.
In the comics, Melina Vostokoff is a former
Russian agent also known as Iron Maiden, who
becomes resentful of Black Widow and attempts
to kill her.
In the Black Widow trailer, Melina's nefarious
intentions towards Natasha aren't made obvious
and instead we see her with Nat, Yelena and
Red Guardian, reuniting for a meal as if they
are old friends:
"Family..
Back together again."
"You got fat."
But Melina's somewhat uncomfortable looks
in that scene suggest she could be hiding
something.
The "scientific experiment" that Rachel Weisz
mentioned might be the creation of David Harbour's
Red Guardian, who in the comics was the Soviet
Union's answer to Captain America.
Or it could be Melina's creation of her own
Iron Maiden suit.
However, I have a feeling that Melina could
actually be responsible for creating Taskmaster
and that the "scientific experiment" is what
ends up giving the villain its powers of mimicry
and duplication.
Interestingly, duplication and mirroring appear
to be a theme in the Black Widow movie that
goes beyond Taskmaster.
For example, when we see Yelena and Natasha
fight each other, they mirror and duplicate
the other's postures and moves.
Obviously, they were also trained under the
same system but this symbolic mirroring seems
to be something the film is pushing thematically
as well.
Here we see all the Black Widow operatives
moving and turning in unison.
And during this aerial freefall, these three
mercs are each performing the same motion,
reminding me a bit of clones.
The real question to ask ourselves here is
whether Melina will be the person inside the
Taskmaster costume or did she experiment on
somebody else?
Well, there's actually a sneaky clue that
can help answer this in one of the other Taskmaster
scenes from the trailer.
When we see the villain go up against Red
Guardian in a one-on-one fight, there's an
interesting visual perspective on how the
two characters compare in terms of height.
If we draw a line, we can see there's only
a slight difference in height, with Taskmaster
appearing to be just a little shorter than
Red Guardian.
According to IMDB, Rachel Weisz who plays
Melina is 5ft 6 inches tall, whereas David
Harbour, aka Red Guardian, is almost nine
inches taller at nearly 6ft 3.
That's a much bigger height difference than
this fight scene would suggest.
Admittedly, both characters aren't standing
straight so we can't measure the height difference
exactly, but they both have their knees bent
by roughly the same amount, and neither one
is wearing significantly thicker boots that
would boost their height.
It's unlikely therefore that this is Melina
in the Taskmaster outfit.
Now, there is actually another main Black
Widow cast member who would fit in that costume
and that's actor O.T.
Fagbenle who's 6ft exactly, making him just
3 inches shorter than David Harbour which,
when we look at this picture, seems to be
about the right amount.
Fagbenle, best known for his work in The Handmaid's
Tale, is playing a character called Mason
in Black Widow.
In the cast interview with EW, he described
Mason as "a fixer, […] the guy who can get
things done if you're a spy or superhero and
need a little bit of extra help."
The actor also revealed that Mason "has a
bit of a complex relationship" with Natasha
and a romantic interest in her.
Mason's name or Nat's prior relationship with
him has never been mentioned or discussed
in previous MCU movies, which could mean the
filmmakers will use that to show that their
relationship didn't go well and Natasha never
wanted to bring it up.
In the comics, Mason worked for SHIELD, but
he also had a freelance background working
as a covert operative where he was simply
known as "The Agent".
Given Black Widow is a super-spy movie, it's
also quite possible that Mason is some kind
of double-agent who works both for SHIELD
and the Russians or Melina specifically.
I think it's interesting that Fagbenle chooses
not to reveal which side Mason works for in
the interview with EW, especially as he exchanges
a subtle glance with Rachel Weisz while describing
Mason's role in the film.
"He's like a fixer..
He's kind of the guy who can get things done..
..if you're a spy or a superhero and you need
a bit of extra help.
Ahhm.. sort you out..
..I'm still..
I work.. all the time.."
And notice how Rachel Weisz smiles knowingly
to herself when the interviewer initially
asks O.T. to talk about his character.
"So O.T. tell us a bit about.. the character
that you play."
Oh yeah, I play erm..
Mason and er.."
Given all this and how little has been revealed
about O.T.'s role in Black Widow, all clues
currently point to him being Taskmaster.
Of course, some fans have speculated that
Yelena could be masquerading as Taskmaster.
If we go by the height theory though, then
she'd be the least likely candidate, as Florence
Pugh at around 5ft 4 is almost a whole foot
shorter than Red Guardian actor David Harbour.
Additionally, given Natasha's fate in Endgame,
this film will probably serve as a way to
set up a new Black Widow character for future
MCU movies and it looks like Yelena is the
most likely candidate for that right now.
So, who do you think Taskmaster really is
underneath the helmet?
I've created a poll where you can vote.
Just tap in the top-right to make your prediction
and to see the results.
Thanks again to Marvel Collect!
By Topps for sponsoring this video and don't
forget to download the app from the link below
and collect 5 free collectibles this month
for a chance to win this amazing giveaway.
Next tap left to check out another Marvel
video or tap right for something else you're
sure to like.
And if you enjoyed this, a thumbs-up and a
share are hugely appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!